So today we find ourselves in a very
different novelistic world than we've been
in for the last week and
a half on the road. Um,
did anyone take this course
because they love on the road?
Anybody one sort of
ambivalently yes. Okay.
Sometimes I do get students who,
um,
have just an image of this novel in their
mind or they read it when they were in
high school and have a sort of irrational,
passionate love for it. Um, and,
and so sometimes people
approach it in that way.
And I think in a way it holds that aura
around itself in our culture and in the
history of the novel in this period
that we're studying together.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about it's publishing history.
Um,
it's compositional history actually at
the end of my two lectures on the novels.
So I would ask you just to reserve
whatever curiosity you have about that.
Um, so I, in a way, I'm
flipping my usual practice.
I would tell you a little bit about its
publication history at the beginning.
I'm going to do that at the end.
Um,
for this reason that it has such a
special place in the imagination of our
culture and so I'm going to talk about
that after we have a better understanding
of what's going on in the book.
My point at the end of my lecture on the
Lita on Monday was that [inaudible] is
trying to imagine an autonomous work
of art that has a life to it that is in
some sense animated or personified,
and that this desire to make the aesthetic
something living introduces to the
world of the aesthetic,
the problem of mortality,
it's mortality that gives it
that sense of ephemeral value,
but it's also mortality that
threatens to cancel it out altogether.
The language that the beets tried to
imagine tried to write takes up some of
these problems that we saw in Dubach off.
Unlike Novakof,
these writers are not trying to make a
language that is autonomous and separate
from the world,
so you will not see the kind of artifice
and the Labor detention to form.
You're not going to have a writer spending
a month on the representation of a
barber from Kaz beam. You're not
going to get that in the beats. Um,
instead you're getting something,
a language that tries to
come as close as possible,
not necessarily to life in all its facets,
but to life as we experience it
in a certain way.
This is not a rejection of modernism and
its desire for the autonomous work of
art. Um, because partly as I've shown the,
I like the desire for the autonomous
work of art shades into the desire to
replicate life.
There is that desire much more explicitly
in the writing of Jack Kerouac,
the desire to replicate experience
as you read the feeling of having the
experience that the writer wants you
to have and that the writer himself has
had, that's always going to be important,
um, to understanding this work.
So that's one aspect in which it
shares something with modernism.
Even though stylistically and as
a matter of craft and composition,
it looks very distinct.
The other way it shares an ambition of
modernism is precisely in that effort to
communicate experience consciousness.
So if you've read it all in the novels
of, for a Virginia Woolf, for example,
or in James Joyce's novels,
you know,
that part of modernist innovation,
part of the stylistic difficulty is the
effort to put on the page what happens
in the mind,
that sense of the mind drifting from
one idea to another that you get in
Virginia Woolf's prose.
So magically in Woolf's prose.
So that is something these
writer's share with modernism.
But there's one big difference and I
want to exemplify that for you just by
reading to you two parallel texts,
one from the modernist Canon
and one from the beat Canon.
So first I want to read to you,
um,
the footnote to ts Elliot's the wasteland.
Now,
the wasteland was the first,
uh,
the first poem to have footnotes
and you have to ask yourself,
what do you have to think? The poem is in
order to think that it needs footnotes.
Um, so I'm going to, uh, say
a little bit more about that,
but let me just read to you first,
um, from the notes on the wasteland,
not only the title,
but the plan.
And a good deal of the
incidental symbolism of the
poem were suggested by Miss
Jesse l Weston's book on the grail
legend from ritual to Romance Cambridge.
He has a little bibliography there.
Indeed.
So deeply am I indebted
Miss Weston's book.
Will Lucy elucidate the difficulties of
the poem much better than my notes can
do and I recommend it apart from the
great interest of the book itself to any
who think such elucidation of the poem
worth the trouble to another work of
anthropology.
I am indebted in general one which has
influenced our generation profoundly.
I mean the golden bough I have used,
especially the two volumes,
Adonis Atis,
oh Cyrus,
anyone who was acquainted with these
works will immediately recognize in the
poem certain references
to vegetation ceremonies.
And then there are particular notes,
uh, for the different parts of the poem.
That's the introduction to the footnotes.
What I want you to note there is the
sense that the matter of the poem comes
from an archive and
archive of scholarly work,
a body of knowledge that you read about.
So now, and I also want you to note
that language, Miss Jessie Western.
It's a very mannered decorous language.
Now
I would like to read to you from
the footnote to how Allen Ginsburg's
famous poem that for many people embodied
at the time what it meant to be
engaged in this new literary project.
So this is footnote to how
holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy,
holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy, holy.
The world is holy.
That is holy.
The skin is holy.
The nose is holy.
The Tang and cock and hand and Asshole,
holy,
everything is wholly, everybody's
holy. Everywhere is wholly.
Every day is in eternity.
Every man's in angel,
the bums as holy as the Sarah Fim.
The Madman is holy.
As you my soul are wholly,
the typewriter is holy.
The poem is holy.
The voices holy,
the hearers are wholly the
ecstasy is holy. Holy Pete,
her Holy Allen,
Holy Solomon,
Holy Lucian, holy Kerouac,
holy Hunka, holy Burroughs,
holy Cassidy, holy. The unknown,
buggered and suffering beggars.
Holy.
The hideous human angel colts.
Little different tone,
don't you?
Few things I want to note about that.
Besides the obvious,
the fallout of poetic inspiration
is not to be found in an archive.
It is not be found in Miss Jessie
Weston's book on ritual and Romance.
It is not to be found with a
bibliography saying Cambridge.
Okay.
That's not where you find
the fount of the great poem.
The footnote to Howell says
that the source of Howell,
that's what footnotes.
Are there an indication of the source?
It says that the source of the poetry
is that wholly lived experience
and a particular slice
of lived experience.
The formerly rejected the
in decorous the ecstatic.
I noticed that,
um,
several of you were smiling in a way
as I read that suggested you were
embarrassed by the performance.
Right.
I did not elicit this by accident.
Embarrassment is something
that the beats value.
Yeah.
When Ginsburg first read Howl,
okay.
He, uh, he was on stage and there
was a little bathroom was that,
this was an in, uh, um, I think it was
in a bookstore. I can't remember. I,
I didn't reread my notes on how,
um,
and so when the show started,
he was,
he was in the bathroom on the pot with
the door open and then he sorta hiked.
He got up and he hiked up his
pants and he walked out and he,
he gave his reading of how
this is indicative of the
sense that he wants to lay
bare in a literal way,
all the see Munis of human life,
all the aspects of what it
means to be an embodied person.
All the ecstasies that
come from that embodiment.
And of course this is not at
all original to Ginsburg. Uh,
if you read Walt Whitman,
you will see much, uh,
much of the same ethos and
probably a lot better poetry. Um,
so Ginsburg is not the first to do this
in the American tradition for sure,
but it's a very important
part of what the beats revive.
And I want to get at that question of
embarrassment because it comes up very
explicitly on page 36
embarrassment is the
monetized in on the road.
Okay.
And it's assigned what I think
is a very interesting provenance.
So this is Chad king
talking to sal paradise.
Uh,
quavering twain comes out when he speaks.
The thing I always liked sell about the
plains Indians was the way they always
got sedan and embarrassed after they
boasted the number of scalps they got in
Roxanne's life in the far west.
There's an Indian who gets all red over
blushing because he thought so many
scalps and he runs like hell into the
plains to glory over his deeds in hiding.
Damn,
that tickled me.
This sense of embarrassment is the sense
that the excess of what joy in this,
uh, in this, um, passage,
the Indians bravery, his
achievement, his success,
all of that is in excess of the decorous
presentation of that experience,
of that real world of life,
of that excessive joy.
And it's given here this sort of cliched
noble origin with the native American,
the plains Indian.
So there's a sense in the plains Indian
that he is both the embodiment of a
noble restrained lineage,
but also deepen that American
past is this sense of,
of great access.
Embarrassment tells us we're
in the presence of the excess.
And that's why beat writers court
it, that's why I courted it. Um,
today for you,
the excess requires for the
beets a new kind of language,
one aspect of their language,
which maybe you've noticed it on the road.
It's not quite so pronounced and
on the road as it is elsewhere,
certainly in the letters that, that
these figures right to each other. Um,
part of that is the
elimination of small words,
VI and um,
the abbreviation of certain words,
your to why are there all kinds of
little abbreviations they they make.
And it suggests that language has to
be wrenched out of its conventions.
Syntax can be set aside,
language needs to move at the speed of
experience and at the speed of ecstasy.
So that's one small way in the
language that they practiced,
tried to imitate the experience that
they were a immersing themselves in.
Um, but there were more formulated,
formulated,
um,
ways of capturing that experience
in language. Jack Kerouac,
uh,
had a list of essential that he taped
up on his wall when he was writing.
Um,
and this is what they include,
scribbled secret notebooks and wild
type written pages for your own joy.
And that's why our your own joy,
submissive to everything,
open listening,
tried never to get drunk outside your own
house. Well this is a piece of advice.
Clearly he never took.
Be In love with your life.
Be Crazy dumb.
Seem to have the mind blow
as deep as you want to blow,
right what you want.
Bottomless from bottom of the mind,
the unspeakable visions of the individual
entranced fixation,
dreaming upon object before you.
And then my st my,
my favorite one is you're
a genius all the time.
Now try putting that up in front of
your desk. You're a genius all the time.
It will help you to produce a
lot of writing. I guarantee. Um,
Kerouac tried over and over again to
write on the road and it was an effort to
practice this kind of free language
that would be uninhibited and that would
gesture towards some deeper,
bottomless part of the human experience.
The human soul. Sometimes
it was spiritualized. Um,
in this sense, this is why I put this
quote up on the board from on the road.
We've got to go some place,
find something.
There's a relentless seeking sense
that's at the heart of this work.
Now, for those of you who
don't know, I'm on the road,
does document pretty closely the actual
road trips that Jack Kerouac took,
uh, with Neal Cassady and
a whole host of others.
And I can do a little decoding for you.
Old Bully is William
Burroughs and his wife,
Jane Jane Lee.
Um,
Hunka, I can't remember who
Hunka is now in the book.
These are some minor characters who
lived with them and went to Columbia with
them or were in their circle when these
writers lived in the neighborhoods in
New York,
around Columbia University.
So Alan Ginsburg is Carlo marks.
Um,
and Ginsburg went to Columbia.
He was kicked out of Columbia,
um, and then sort of went
back, was in and out of school.
So a lot of them were in this little
community and they picked up wanderers and
various people who, um,
wanted to learn from them.
And that's what Neal Cassady,
uh,
was to them at first I kind of wander or
who wanted to be in their intellectual,
uh,
but Bohemian circle.
Okay.
So you see the kind of
language that Neal represents,
um, at the very beginning
of the novel. First of all,
he's introduced in this
very mysterious way.
Yeah.
First reports of him, this is on,
on the first page of part one.
The middle of that first paragraph,
first reports of him came to me
through Chad King, who'd known,
who showed me a few letters from him
written in New Mexico reformed school.
So his letters come out
of this western land,
New Mexico and a land of criminality,
the reform school.
So he's exotic just from the very
beginning and it's an exotic language.
It's the letters that come out of this
exotic place that first catch their
attention.
Yeah.
I was tremendously interested in
the letters because they so naive.
Lee and sweetly ask Chad to teach him
all about Nicha and all the wonderful
intellectual things that Chad knew.
At one point Carlo and I talked about
the letters and wondered if we would ever
meet the strange Dean Moriarty.
This is all far back when Dean was not
the way he is today when he was a young
jail kid.
Shrouded in mystery.
Then news came that dean was out of reform
school and was coming to New York for
the first time.
Also there was talk that he had
just married a girl called Mary Lou.
It's that passive sense.
There was talk who's talking?
We don't know.
That passive verb there was talk
gives you the sense that
there's this wide community
passing word mouth to mouth of the
coming of a mysterious spiritual figure.
First reports of him news came.
There was talk.
So language is this communal set of
rumors spiritualized by its very vagueness
and shared quality
and then it's just fascinating
to listen to what Dean says.
No, this is on page two.
This is how he talks.
All this time dean was telling Mary
Lou things like this. Now Darling,
here we are in New York and although I
haven't quite told you everything that I
was thinking about when we about when we
crossed the Missouri Cross Missouri and
especially at the point when we passed
the Boonville were reformatory which
reminded me of my jail problem.
It is absolutely necessary now to post
pone all those leftover things concerning
our personal love things and at once
begin thinking of specific work work life
plans and so on in the way
he had in those early days.
His language is a sort of mishmash
of poorly used academic locations,
work life plans. It sounds almost
like a corporate speak in a way.
It has that, that um, dry quality to it.
Yeah.
And then on the top of three
we get another example.
In other words, we've got to get on
the ball, darling. What I'm saying.
Otherwise it'll be fluctuating and lack
of true knowledge or crystallization of
our plans.
So this is not yet that idealized speech
that cure wack is dreaming of when he
writes the list of essential
for spontaneous prose.
That's deans language is not that
in these passages is desire for the
intellectual download from Chad is not
what's going to make him the figure of
the new language for so
okay.
Rather it is another kind of language
that he represents that will be that kind
of germ of what sal was looking for.
This is UC also want to,
at the beginning here
I went to the cold water flat with the
boys and dean came to the door in his
shorts.
Mary Lou was jumping off the couch.
Dean had dispatched the occupant of the
apartment to the kitchen probably to
make coffee while he proceeded
with his love problems for to him,
sex was the one and only holy
and important thing in life.
Although he had to sweat and
curse to make a living and so on.
You saw that in the way he stood
bobbing his head, always looking down,
nodding like a young boxer to insert two
instructions to make you think he was
listening to every word throwing in
a thousand yeses and that's right.
There's this sense of enthusiasm.
So his response is not an
articulation of some thought,
but in a fusion. Yes, that's right.
It's a visceral response and you
see it even more clearly on four.
Okay.
So he's staying,
Dean is staying with sound
and sal has writing and they're
ready to go out and sell.
Says, hold on a minute,
I'll be right with you.
As soon as I finish this chapter and it
was one of the best chapters in the book.
Then I dressed and off we flew
to New York to meet some girls.
So I'm going to skip along a little
bit. Um, I was, uh, let's see.
As we, uh, actually I'm going
to read that part. As we rose,
as we wrote in the bus in the weird
phosphorescent void of the Lincoln tunnel,
we leaned on each other with fingers
waving and yelled and talk to excitedly.
And I was beginning to get the bug.
Like Dean, he was simply a youth,
tremendously excited with life.
And though he was a con man,
he was only calling because he wanted
so much to live and get involved with
people who would otherwise
pay no attention to him.
He was calling me and I knew it for room
and board and how to write, et Cetera,
and he knew. I knew this had been
the basis of our relationship,
but I didn't care and we got along
fine. No pestering, no catering.
We tiptoed around each other
like heartbreaking new friends.
I began to learn from him as much as he
probably learned from me as far as my
work was concerned. He said, go
ahead. Everything you do is great.
He watched over my shoulder
as I wrote stories yelling.
Yes, that's right. Wow Man.
And Phew.
Wow is dean's word.
Wow is the kind of word
that means nothing,
but it suggests the immediacy
of Dean's engagement.
So all that talking on the bus and the
way they're moving their hands, the bug,
that's all where this
language is rising from.
That's where the new language
it was going to come from.
And you can see how so
assimilates that on page 35
this is just as he is coming into Denver.
I said to myself,
wow,
what will Dan for me like I got on that
hot road and off I went in a brand new
car driven by Denver businessmen
of about 35 he went 70.
I tingled all over accounted minutes and
subtracted miles just to head over the
rolling wheat fields, fields, all golden
beneath the distance snows of SDS.
I'd be seeing old Denver at last.
I pictured myself in a Denver bar that
night with all the gang and in their eyes
I would be strange and ragged and like
the prophet who has walked across the
land to bring the dark word and
the only word I had was wow.
Yeah.
So Neil's so I mean, uh, sorry. Yeah.
Um, dean sense, I will do
this and please forgive me.
I will sometimes slip into calling
him dean because he didn't, uh, sorry.
Do you ever mind, you
know what I'm saying? Um,
I will sometimes slip into calling
him kneel when his name is dean. Um,
Dean
has already projected this
motive language into south.
So even as he's saying to south,
teach me how to write,
what he's doing is
teaching sao how to write,
how to write this kind of book,
how to be the prophet of wow.
Okay.
This is all over the text. If
you look at on 62, page 62,
some of these little stories, Remy
woke up and saw me come in the window,
his great laugh,
one of the greatest laughs in
the world [inaudible] in my ear.
And then if you just
skip up to the top of 63,
the strange thing was that next door
to Remy lived in Negro called Mr. Snow.
Who's laugh I swear on
the Bible was positively.
And finally the one greatest
laugh in all this world.
The laugh is a lot like the wow.
It's that sound you make just because
you're experiencing something just because
you're having a response to what's in
front of you. Something someone says.
Okay, that's another example. Um, and
the last one I'll give you is on 55.
This is when they've gone up
to the mountain pass after
getting in fights in the
bars in Denver in the whole eastern dark
wall of the divide this night there was
silence and the whisper of the wind,
except in the ravine where we roared.
And on the other side of the divide
was the great western slope and the big
plateau that went to steamboat springs,
springs and dropped and led you to the
western Colorado Desert and the Utah
desert all in darkness. Now as we fumed
and screamed in our mountain nook,
mad drunk and Americans
in the mighty land,
we were on the roof of America
and all we could do was yell,
I guess across the night eastward over
the plains where somewhere in old man
with white hair was probably walking
towards us with the word and would arrive
any minute and make us silent
there,
yell at the top of the world,
seems to sow something that
calls for a replacement.
It calls for some other profit to come
walking ragged towards them and make them
fall silent with his word.
But in the meantime,
what you have is the continual
reproduction of that yell,
that laugh that wow, that, yes, that,
that's all right.
All those things they say just to register
their existence and their relation
with one another.
I want to note something else though about
the first time that Dean and sal meat
and the contextualizing of that meeting,
when they first meet in that
passage that I read to you,
he's just rising up from having sex on
the couch with Mary Lou in someone else's
apartment.
He sent the owner of the apartment into
the kitchen so he could have sex with
Mary Lou on the couch. In other
versions, he says that, um,
that dean got up and was naked,
not that he was in his shorts.
There's an immediate sexual sense that
charges the relationship between these
people.
It also,
those relationships take place in the
context of continual negotiations of
sexual relationships.
And so the book begins with that
explanation that I first met Dean not long
after my wife and I split up.
I had just gotten over a serious illness
that I won't bother to talk about
except that it had something to do with
the miserably weary splitting up in my
feeling that everything was dead.
Deans negotiations between Mary Lou
and Camille in Denver where he has his
schedule and he has this exact time he
has to get from one hotel to the other to
sleep with each of them. And then he
has to meet Carlo Ginsburg in the,
I mean this bird Carlo marks in
the basement in the basement,
uh,
to have his,
his conversations to get to the
bottom lessness of each other's mind.
All those negotiations
are absolutely crucial.
It's what they spend
their time talking about.
Often it's what they spend
their time negotiating.
So the search for the immediate language
of experience is part and parcel of a
very complex negotiation of sexual
ties between multiple people.
And it's not just between
the men and the women,
it's between the men and the
men. And that moment when, um,
when south meets dean at
the door and he's naked,
it's reflected when he
sees dean with Camille.
Camille opens the door to their room when
they're in Denver and he finally sees
dean in Denver.
He opens the door to the room and there's
a picture that Camille has drawn of
Dean, a portrait of him completely
naked. And it notes, you know, his,
his penis.
In that picture
it says,
if Sal's first experience of
Dean is already in that scene,
assimilated into the image of Dean,
the disembodied aesthetic image of dean.
But that aesthetic image of Dean is
all bound up in these negotiations.
So it's a picture that Camille has drawn.
And of course Camille doesn't know that
he's sleeping with Mary Lou in another
hotel on the same day and so on.
So all of that is very palpable and Sal's
own desire for Dean is sublimated in
those scenes,
but it's everywhere at
the level of the language.
And if you note the repeated
presence of that question,
where was dean, where was
dean? He's always missing.
When sal gets to Denver,
that's what he wants to know.
When he gets back to New York. Finally
at the end of this first road trip,
he has missed dean. There's always
the sense that dean evades him,
and I think part of that sense of any
vacating object of desire is again,
the pursuit of sex in this novel.
It's part of the pursuit of sex.
Yeah.
You might think given all this and
given the ultimate plot of on the road,
that being on the road is about
pursuing that kind of desire,
and that is necessitated by leaving home.
You have to leave home in
order to pursue that desire.
But I would suggest to you that home is
absolutely crucial to the production of
this desire.
And I want to point you to page 26
this is south story about
big slim hazard.
A Hobo that he wants knew as a little boy.
Oh,
so he was a hobo by
choice as a little boy.
He'd seen a Hobo come up to ask
his mother for a piece of Pie,
and she had given it to him.
And when the Hobo went off down the road,
the little boy had said,
my work was that fellow.
Why that's a Hobo Ma.
I want to be a Hobo someday.
Shut your mouth.
That's not for the like of the hazards,
but he never forgot that day.
And when he grew up after a short
spell playing football at Lsu,
he did become a hobo.
Being a Hobo is produced in this little
vignette by the experience of seeing a
Hobo get pie from your mother.
Now,
did any of you notice
how often sal eats pie?
Let me just demonstrate
the litany of Pi. Okay. Page 15
yes.
Actually, let's start
on 14 or perhaps on 13
hmm.
13 along about three in the morning
after an apple pie and ice cream in a
roadside stand.
That's so top of 14 I ate
another apple pie and ice cream.
That's practically all I ate
all the way across the country.
I knew it was nutritious
and it was delicious. 15
bottom. I ate apple pie and ice
cream. It was getting better.
As I got deeper into Iowa, the
pie bigger, the ice cream richer.
There were the most beautiful
bevies of girls everywhere.
I looked in Des Moines that afternoon.
They were coming home from high school,
but I had no time now for thoughts
like that and promised myself a ball in
Denver.
And if you look on one oh seven,
the first thing sell does when he
gets home is eat. When I got home,
I ate everything in the icebox.
My mother got up and looked at me.
Poor little Salvatore. She said, in
Italian, you are Theon, you're thin.
Where have you been? All this time I
had on two shirts and two sweaters.
My canvas bag had torn cotton field pants
and the tattered remnants of my Herati
shoes in it.
My aunt and I decided to buy a new
electric refrigerator with the money I had
sent her from California.
It was to be the first one in the family.
There is a sense in which hunger,
the hunger generated by
the road in south case.
In this last scene he's been panelists.
All he had was cough drops
to eat at the very end. Um,
that the hunger generated by the road
exists in a necessary relation to the
consumption of home.
And I would suggest to you that the
consumption of home is driven by a certain
kind of desire as well.
That desire to move up in
the American class structure,
the first electric
refrigerator in my family,
he's earned a little money
on the road and sent it home.
What it does for him is
allow him to buy his aunt,
this symbol of a middle class American
domesticity and he is a happy participant
in this new purchase.
This is not exactly just what the women
do while the boys are out on the road.
The boys want the pie.
The boys want to become hobos because
there's a kind of hunger that's generated
at home.
It's satisfied at home,
but it's also generated at home.
And I want to suggest to you that
part of the misogyny of the novel,
which I'm sure is palpable to all of
us as we read part of that misogyny is
connected to this consumptive ethos.
So when we talk about
desire for something,
we've got to go some place,
find some thing.
The very vagueness of that desire is
connected with the basic hungers of the
body for sex,
for food,
for sleep. Even we see dean
sort of begging for sleep,
uh, after his conversation with Carlo
marks in the basement in Denver.
Those kinds of desires are connected
also with that American habit of
consumption.
This is a consumer society.
In the 1950s it was already very much so.
The mass production after World
War Two had already taken hold.
Supermarkets as we saw in wise blood are
already something one can be fond of as
Enoch was.
And so if this is a novel whose
aura has always said to us,
be free,
be counter cultural.
What I'm suggesting is that it's
structured around a very deeply embedded
American cultural trait of consumption.
It spiritualizes that kind of desire
and my symbol for it is pie.
Yeah.
One I'll show you one last thing about
how the language works and this is on
page 49
okay.
To set aside the critique
of that search for a moment.
I just want to move back into it in
these spiritual terms and see what we can
see.
When Dean and Carlo are
talking to each other,
there's a lot of anxiety on either
part about whether they have actually
attained that thing that
they were looking for.
On 48 they're talk is decide is
described as business in the beginning.
Then they got down to business.
They sat on the bed,
cross legged and looked at each other.
I slouched in a nearby
chair and saw all of it.
They began with an abstract thought,
disgust.
It reminded each other of
another abstract point.
Forgotten in the rush of events,
Dean apologized but promised he could
get back to it and manage it. Fine,
bringing up illustrations and then they
have this very complicated back and
forth about things that they remembered
or didn't and they hash these things
over.
Okay.
Then Carlo as dean,
if he was honest and specifically if he
was being honest with him in the bottom
of his soul,
why do you bring that up again?
There's one last thing I want to
know, but dear sal, you're listening.
You're sitting there, we'll ask
cell. What would he say? And I said,
that last thing is what you can't get,
Carlo,
nobody can get to that last thing.
We keep on living in hopes
of catching it once for all.
Yeah.
So all this language is produced because
you can't ever get to that last thing.
You have to keep hashing it over. But
if you, if you, um, go to the next page,
yeah,
you can see actually two pages over.
You can see that already sao is taking
what he can get from this language and
transposing it into his
experience of reality.
So Carlo had earlier, just,
sorry to flip back and forth.
So much had had,
had read earlier his poem,
this is on 47, um, to sell. He's,
he'd been reading poetry.
Carla woke up in the morning and heard
the vulgar pigeons yakking in the street
outside his cell.
He saw the sad Nightingale's nodding on
the branches and they reminded him of
his mother. A gray shroud fell
over the city, the mountains,
the magnificent Rockies that you can see
to the west from any part of town where
paper machine say the whole universe
was crazy and cockeyed and extremely
strange. So this is what Carlo
represents in his poetry. Well,
if you look Sao after
witnessing what it means,
what their business is with one another,
the way they try to get to the
bottom of each other's soul.
Yeah,
he looks out and he sees the
world through Carlos eyes.
He's been awake though all this time.
Listening. What were you thinking, Sal?
I told them that I was thinking they
were very amazing maniacs and that I had
spent the whole night listening to them
like a man watching the mechanism of a
watch that reached clear to the top of
Berta to burritoed pass and was yet made
with the smallest works of the most
delicate watch in the world. They smiled.
I pointed my finger at them and said, if
you keep this up, you'll both go crazy,
but let me know what
happens as you go along.
I walked out and took a trolley to my
apartment and Carlo Marx's paper machine
mountains grew red as the great
sun rose from the eastward plains.
So the poetry that is part and
parcel of the between Dean and Carlo,
Carlos Poetry seeps out of that
basement room and there's a,
a real spatial sense here that it's being
generated at the base of the world and
it goes up in, it transforms
these mountains into paper mushy.
It makes them in one sense,
false.
There's a falseness to the overlay that
Carlo gives to sal and through which he
then sees there's a falseness,
a craftiness,
but it's a kind of folk craftiness.
This is not the craftiness of modernism.
This is paper machete,
a fairly crude folk art.
Anyone can do it,
get your strips of
newspaper and paste them up.
So it has a quality that is different
from Humberto elaborate worldview through
which we see or don't see Lolita.
It's a very different kind of crafting,
but yet it does replace reality in a
similar way or it makes demands on reality
that pushed the real back.
And so even though they can never
get to the bottom of their souls,
they can never get a cell says
that last thing you could.
That's what you could never have.
Even though that's true,
it has this world making power.
To what end will that power be used?
This is one question I want you to
think about as you finish this novel.
What do these figures think
language can be used for?
What's it good for?
What can it do for them?
What beyond that kind
of economics of desire,
that accounting,
if you look on 1-081-OH-SEVEN-108 again,
the very end of the section,
I had my home to go to my place to lay
my head down and figure the losses and
figure the gain that I knew
was in there somewhere too.
What are the losses?
What are the gains?
Is it just a representation of an
imaginative and desire full economy,
or is there some other
thing being produced here?
What is the sump thing?
What is the someplace?
So in that relation,
I'd like you to think about the
representation of America in the novel.
What do you see there when
you think about the America?
They're giving us all these figures,
so that's free or reading in
section. Um, please bring Lolita.
I think you're going to spend most of
your time talking about Lolita section for
on the road.
We'll probably be next week unless
you're TF wants to bring up some brief
questions about it. Um,
but that's all for today.